if you could be any superhero what
superpower would you want to have I bet
you're thinking about it aren't you well
growing up believe it or not this was
something my friends and I would think
about a lot where you get really excited
and we say things like I want to fly
like Superman or I want to be able to
read 10,000 words a minute as a parent
started to listen in my answer though
was always consistent I want to make
people laugh at this point you might be
wondering how is that a superpower I
would argue that it is going up my
father was a professional comedian and I
was always fascinated because he could
get away with pretty much anything you
can ask my mom I wanted to be just like
him as it turns out I'm a business
school so that didn't quite work out but
I learned an even bigger lesson that
humor can actually teach us serious
lessons about how we can better relate
with each other
lessons I didn't quite set out to learn
in fact my dad didn't set out to be a
comedian either 20 years ago he moved
back from the United States to his home
country Ghana after studying acting in
the United States it was a pivotal time
in Ghana's history for the first time we
had democratic elections after two
decades of a military dictatorship it
was a time of a lot of excitement a lot
of hope but yet that necessary dose of
skepticism that newly democratic
countries tend to have and my father
could be pretty stubborn when he was
convinced of an idea and he was
convinced that the only way this new
democrasy would work is if we talked
openly about what was not working
so to make his point he goes on to radio
and of course the first thing he does is
publicly criticized the government as
you can imagine that didn't go down too
well public reaction to him was intense
his car was vandalized people wrote him
some pretty creative hate mail and their
sponsor has actually pulled out from the
show labeling him as overly
controversial fast forward a couple
years later he returns to his first love
which is acting so he performs in his
first one-man play originally set out to
be a drama but the audience actually
ended up laughing so much that it was
written about as one of Ghana's best
comedy plays of all time and that is how
he became a comedian why am I telling
you the story it's because in that in
that play he spoke about the exact same
issues he used to talk about on radio
this time though people drive more than
five hours line up and pay just to
listen to him that ladies and gentlemen
is the power of humor that is why I
think it's a superpower and that is why
I wanted to be just like him this
fascination with a power of humor stayed
with me through the years and actually
ended up working in the industry I
worked as a producer for a comedy show I
learned some pretty hard lessons very
quickly the most important being I'm not
funny
in fact when I told my brother that I
wanted to make people laugh for a living
he was quiet for a minute looks at me
and says I've left a lot because of you
dis Decker
so I took a different approach and I
thought to understand what it was about
humor that enables us to let our guard
down and connect so instantly and what I
found through my research and my work is
that the magic of humor is that it's
unexpected
in fact our brain works with pattern
recognition so basically when you hear a
story you subconsciously try to
autocomplete it but when the story goes
in a different direction we experience
this rush from the surprise factor humor
works because we delight in the
unexpected when it's coming from a good
place
research shows that our brains pleasure
Center actually is far more reactive to
experiences that are both pleasurable
and unexpected than experiences that are
simply pleasurable it's the reason why
surprise wedding proposals work so well
most of the time but how does this
connect us well think back to the last
time you laughed
hopefully that was a few minutes ago
think about how you felt towards the
person that made you laugh when we
experienced this rush our brain captures
and holds that emotional memory so the
next time we meet again we associate
this positive memory with the person and
warm up more quickly in other words if
you make a guy or girl laugh on the
first date you're probably gonna get a
second one so we know how humor connects
and affects us but not all of us can be
professional comedians try as we might
and as I've learned to ask myself in
business school how do we apply this
framework of using unexpectedness to
delight each other better yet how do we
scale its effect in our everyday life
and I saw you a quick story that helped
put it all together for me
a couple years ago I lost a bet to one
of my good friend Sarah
and like all our bets I had to buy her
lunch and so I'm standing in line I've
put in my order I'm ready to pay and
tell my embarrassment I've left my
wallet again and then the weirdest thing
happened a guy walks from behind me
swipes his credit card pays for an
entire meal and walks away before I can
even say thank you
and I'm standing there completely
surprised but also delighted and over
the years with similar experiences and
as I've tried to pay it forward I've
come to realize that yes we can delight
each other in small unexpected acts of
kindness think back to the last time
that you received words of encouragement
from a friend you hadn't heard from her
in a while or a friend you just made or
a time a complete stranger let you have
that first parking spot that may be a
little too much to ask in the city but
hopefully you get my point we can all
tap into what makes humor a superpower
by going a little out of our way each
day for the people around us even if
it's as simple as turning to the person
next to you and saying something
thoughtful you look nice today even in
this world
we're often encouraged to think big to
think of impact in terms of touching the
next million or billion lives yet in our
own personal lives we think we're
touched by individual moments and
individual people so my challenge for
you today is to think small will make it
unexpected you'll be pleasantly
surprised thank you
you